j'aime beaucoup ça je sais qu'à y voit
aussi et borgès aussi se méfie des
enfants des miroirs et des romans moi
oui j'aime bien raconter les romans
j'aime raconter des histoires au fond
j'aimerais s'initie dostoïevski n'a pas
trouvé grâce aux yeux de monsieur
miloche le doute de trouver grâce à ses
yeux
mais ce que j'aime c'est raconter des
histoires alors vous vous là où deux
tiers de votre trilogie
oui là bon il ya eu un premier volume
qui s'appelait le vent du soir et dans
ce volume sié qui peut lier ce lien
indépendant indépendamment du volume
précédent
je raconte très simplement l'histoire de
quatre seuls voyons un nom de nom de
famille est imprononçable
enfin mon nom de famille le nom de
famille irlandaise elles ont du sang
irlandais l'ont du sang italien elles
ont du sens rue ce qui explique
peut-être qu'elles vont avoir des tas
d'aventurés retrait elle s'appelle vous
voyez d'où vient le nom de franz qui est
elle s'appelle pandora atalanta vanessa
et jessica j'ai toujours été un peu
fasciné par les soeurs je suis un peu
entouré de deux familles deux soeurs et
dans l'histoire les familles deux soeurs
m'ont beaucoup intéressé il y à un
banquier chinois qui s'appelle son qui
avait trois filles une des filles a
épousé zhang kai shek et sonia mouvement
nationaliste et sa soeur avait épousé
signate scène et deux nuls à peu près
communiste alors vous voyez tous un état
d'assurer plus je ne cacherai pas que je
me suis inspiré en partie de cinq soeurs
extraordinaire qui s'appelle les soeurs
mitford avec un livre avec découvre
qu'elle a un livre a été consacré et
naturellement j'ai toujours dû un petit
peu baissé la réalité parce que la
réalité est trop forte
alors mes quatre heures donc le jeu
ponctualité enfin l'une des soeurs il y
en a une quand on lit bien la maîtresse
du rudolf l année à l'autre se fait un
enfant par scott fitzgerald
la troisième tombe amoureuse d'un homme
le jour où l'avait au lendemain de ses
noces de sang c'est vrai oui alors ya là
une quête une femme fatale ce papa de
rang qui est celle que je préfère
d'ailleurs c'est la plus belle si vous
la connaissiez vous savez les femmes
fatales
vous voyez bien su allait elle est très
belle elle traîne tous les hommes
derrière elle elle était un peu comme
elle est
à l'époque ce qu'est marie mines
aujourd'hui mind monroe mais à l'époque
c'était tout de même un peu plus rares
et au fond je crois qu'elle est
finalement assez malheureuse mais elle
cherche le bonheur et elle est la
maîtresse de garrett coupe de gregory
peck trop tôt oui entre autres et puis
surtout de fitzgerald et c'est durant la
mini moi aussi alors il y en a une autre
qui toutes jeunes tombent amoureuses il
va arriver à quelque chose qui peut
arriver elle tombe amoureuse d'un chef
nazi
elle tombe amoureuse d'un chef nazi qui
est rudolph hess elles étant en voyage
en allemagne elle tombe sur lui par les
ags lit et évidemment ça va l'entraîner
d'un désavantage
alors vous me dites c'est extraordinaire
et bien une des soeurs mitford n'étais
pas amoureuse rudolf hess mais elle
était amoureuse et hitler alors il m'a
semblé que hitler ça ne pouvait pas
passer on n'avait pas vu à mes fins
savons jamais ce sont plutôt simples
auto savoir comme dit très justement
monsieur en amont soit en tout cas la
mienne devient évidemment la maîtresse
de hull fait ce qui va l'entraîner
aventure et puis il ya une deuxième un
peu plus calme et plus calme quasi
plutôt rôle à la fidélité le bode miller
qui a des enfants qui mène une vie
convenable puis c'est un peu le
contrepoint aux autres et puis à la
dernière qui s'appelle jessica et qui
tombe amoureuse elle d'un intellectuel
de gauche d'un d'un type d'oxford vous
savez que oxford et cambridge a été très
tôt ont été très tôt influencé par le
communisme et il est un compagnon de
route elle tombe amoureuse de lui et
elle part avec mis en espagne faire et
d'ailleurs ça se termine à barcelone
alors le il ya une phrase à mon avis qui
résume bien votre roman c'est tout ce
petit monde avec ses secrets et ses
passions il ya deux mots qui dominent
ses secrets et passion dans votre vie il
ya beaucoup de secrets parce qu'il
m'aime d'une société secrète il ya un
esprit du placard ce n'est pas la
télévision française d'ailleurs respect
du critère est ce que les soeurs brontë
ne rentre pas comment toutes les soeurs
il me semble que les soeurs elles seules
les soeurs c'est déjà quelque chose de
romanesque
j'ai connu des familles de 6 j'ai même
connu une famille de 8 celui des soeurs
non des carabins voilà dakar et les
soeurs c'est romanès parce que entre les
soeurs il ya toujours un lien aux pas
des soeurs elle toute seule c'est déjà
un clan c'est une secte
et puis à l'intérieur de ce clan il ya
des rivalités les passions est alors en
plus bon que ce que j'avais fait dans le
vent du soir je vais monter dans le
volume précédent j'avais créé un certain
nombre de davanture avec des histoires
des secrets que les filles quand elles
sont toutes petites les quatre soeurs
découvre peu à peu et qui on peut
imaginer que les aventures des quatre
soeurs sont influencés par leur hérédité
par ce qui s'est passé avant m on peut
imaginer aussi que c'est simplement le
hasard on peut imaginer enfin que c'est
l'histoire qui les emmène en scène
on peut aussi imaginer que jean
d'ormesson raconte les les secousses du
xxème siècle à travers quatre les
passions des 24 bien trop sur ses ratios
du coeur sont éternels sont toujours les
mêmes je crois mais les événements les
passions historique change et ça se
passe dans le décor de la montée du
fascisme et du plein éclat du commune
alors quitte à vous décevoir moi le
personnage que je trouve le mieux dans
votre livre c'est le narrateur qui
s'appelle jean gens comme vous de
plessis vaudreuil et c est un personnage
si si je ne donnant pas du tout parce
qu'il a une importance considérable et
je trouve qu'il est très bien vu ce
personnage parce qu' il existe très
souvent dans des grandes familles il ya
c'est le personnage il est in any cousin
nini il est même pas à l'amendé fille
mais en même temps il est amoureux de
toutes les filles de la maison et des
cas quelque chose qui va mal on
l'appelle parce qu'il est le bon apôtre
il vous l'appelez le saint bernard
d'ailleurs et c'est vrai que ça existe
dans les familles seulement c'est le
confident c'est une sorte de murray ne
sait pas non plus si de tous ces
personnages c'est peut-être le moins
intelligent oui les frères romero ya les
quatre soeurs dont on vient de parler et
puis aller 4-0 qui sont les gens très
brillants bail à l'intellectuel de boue
rouge toxique avec un bridge qui était
un type très très brillant naturellement
qu'en termes il ya des gens en riant
dans votre livre
euh sinon il ya un coureur automobile un
autre frais alors l'histoire automobile
très très brillant très saine
m il commence à pénétrer très brillant
même s'il ya beaucoup d' aventure c'est
plutôt le narrateur qui nuit le succès
il est amoureux de pas ce gentil ça fait
plaisir
j'aime les humbles voilà il est à peu
habile et amoureux de pandora est au
fond il souffre beaucoup de voir ses
filles mener des vies si brillante
arriver tant de choses et lui au fond à
la fin de l'automne il a émis un index
des noms cités jeu tout c'est une bonne
chose
là par exemple on y trouve paul jean
toulet parce que je croise à la fin le
l'une des soeurs enfin celle qui va
mourir je crois site site de calvert du
peu de gens qui s'aiment grave c est
grave ces mots sur le sable rêve de
l'homme est semblable aux illusions de
la mer alors j'en profite pour signaler
que bouquins chez robert laffont vient
de on vient de publier les oeuvres
complètes de paul jean toulet absolu et
c'est ce sabbat si vous laïcité sait pas
où il est mais beaucoup c'est une
édition présentée et annotée par bernard
delvaille je crois que c'est une bonne
occasion de découvrir ou de re lire paul
jean toulet
[Musique]